( intro music )
( applause )
Cory: My story is actually
today-- It's very, very simple.
It's not science.
It's very, very
simple, and it starts
with climbing trees.
This is a photo of me
when I'm, like, two.
My parents are like,
"Yeah, just go get dirty.
Go play."
People are like, "Hey,
your son's up a tree.
"It's 40 feet. That
limb looks pretty ... "
They're like, "He's fine."
Then it's like,
ch, ch, ch, boom.
Then it's like, "Ah, (beep)!"
( laughter )
Here we are in the
emergency room again.
But early on, what
I realized was that
pushing boundaries
has consequences. Right?
Like, that's part of it.
But we have to push boundaries
to understand our limitations.
We have to learn
how far we can go.
You know, that was
ingrained in me very early on,
that pushing boundaries
was something that was important
to not just where I
would be, where I was,
but how far I could take myself.
Early on, I did everything
in the mountains.
That was my life.
That was my family.
But pushing boundaries
became something
a little bit more.
It became about pushing
social boundaries for me.
That ended up becoming
quite a problem.
I was a smart kid.
I was 12 years old when
I went to high school,
and I was a straight A student.
That had its own challenges.
That was pushing
boundaries in its own way.
However, what ended
up happening was,
rather than going out
and climbing or skiing,
or venting my frustrations
as a young kid in high school,
I basically glommed
on to the older kids,
and I started doing
all the wrong things,
hanging out with people
that were more socially
advanced than I was.
I was pushing those boundaries.
I learned very, very
early on that rules,
all of the rules that we follow,
are arbitrary.
There's only one that
actually sticks,
and that's that we all die.
Other than that,
it's all arbitrary.
When you learn that
when you're 14,
and your parents are
like, "You're grounded
if you don't come
home at 11:00."
You're like, "Phh. Whatever."
( laughter )
Maybe that's not
the right boundary to push,
but I was pushing those.
And because of that,
I ended up
being a high school
dropout at 14.
I had gone from being
a straight A student,
to being a high school dropout,
completely on the streets.
I was in rehab three...
Well, I ran away from rehab
three times.
Another boundary
pushing exercise.
The last time I remember
the director of the rehab
looked at me and he said,
"If you leave, you will
end up in the gutter.
You will never
amount to anything,
and you will likely die."
He's actually--
I don't begrudge him
for saying those things.
That's actually fairly correct.
A lot of people that do
end up in that situation
do just fall into the cracks.
But it was because of that time
when I was homeless,
for the most part,
that I started to learn about
the larger human
struggle, that story.
I wanted to tell it.
I wanted to tell people
what I was experiencing,
how I was going through that.
So I used climbing.
I used photography and climbing,
to try to tell that story.
That was my early attempt.
It was beautiful
because it's allegorical
for the struggles we have.
Like this photo,
it looks fantastic.
But the real risks
there are minimal.
They're tiny.
That's a rope.
If he falls, he's safe.
But it's a wonderful
story to tell.
But really early on
climbing for me
was about proving to everybody
that I was not a (bleep) up.
I was just trying to
prove to the world
that I was not that kid that was
going to fall
through the cracks.
I was going to use
the energy that I had
to propel myself
and tell this story,
this larger narrative.
But as I got into that,
I started looking at
people and characters,
the people I was climbing with.
How pushing boundaries
is a transformative
psychological issue.
How we change ourselves
when we do that.
How we continue to learn
through our exercise.
Not just climbing
mountains, but also
how our world is
affected by that.
As I traveled more
and more and more,
and climbed more
I started to observe that world.
All of a sudden,
something that was
very, very much about me,
a selfish pursuit, climbing,
became about telling
the larger story of the planet.
Because I could not move
through these environments
and not care.
That just couldn't happen.
The mountains have always been
a vehicle to voice myself.
So I'd continue to go back,
and I continued to push myself,
and I continued to try.
But that's sort of
taken a little bit
of a back seat.
In 2010, in Pakistan,
we went to climb the first
winter ascent of an
8,000 meter peak,
Gasherbrum II.
But what's interesting is that,
as important as that
climb was for me,
it was more important
for my photography.
Because as you'll see here
in the upper left hand corner
of this,
is the border of
Pakistan and India.
So while I was there,
I was actually talking
with Sadie Quarrier, who is
one of the photo editors here,
and talking about--
She wanted me to exercise
my storytelling capacity.
Climbing was that, I had that,
and my skills
had brought me there.
But what I started
to actually focus on
was this conflict zone.
It's the highest
battleground in the world.
This is the Pakistani military
living on the border
of Pakistan and India.
I became engaged in
using my photography
to tell this larger narrative.
What does it feel like
to be a Pakistani soldier
fighting on the highest
battleground in the world.
What does that look
like texturally?
How do we bring
that back to people?
How do we translate
that experience
for people through imagery?
That was what I
dedicated myself to.
I still keep a very
small collection
on my website that
I'm very proud of it.
I'm very proud of
it because I noticed
that I was pushing
my own boundaries
as a storyteller,
which to me is invaluable.
How do you tell the story
of a broken conflict,
of a broken war?
How do we use media
to translate that experience
for people?
How do we use art to do that?
The first assignment
I did for the magazine
was another step
in that direction,
where we started
bringing together three--
I call it the golden trifecta:
adventure, culture,
and science.
We were using climbing,
I had that skill set,
to go into this
ancient cave complex
in the Kingdom of Mustang.
Mustang is a kingdom
that's on the border
of Nepal and Tibet.
We were trying to
reexamine perhaps
a forgotten path
on the Silk Road.
We were using climbing
to access these ancient
cave complexes.
We were looking
for human remains,
and we found plenty.
We were looking
for burial crypts,
because we needed
the strontium.
The strontium is in
your tooth enamel.
It's an element.
It can tell you where
somebody's born,
based on what's in their
mother's breast milk,
the water we drink.
Now if where they were
born and where they died
is different,
you can start to paint
a picture of human migration.
So all of a sudden,
I was using photography
in a different way.
It was not about adventure.
It wasn't about
necessarily being
in the highest
mountains in the world.
But it was about communicating
science to people
in a tangible way,
in a way that engaged them
and gripped them.
But it's never
been enough for me
to just stay in one spot.
I'm not good at it.
Ask my wife.
Ask my parents.
They're like, "You're a mess."
I'm like, "I got to
get on another plane."
They're like, "You
got back 4 hours ago.
"Just relax, dude."
( laughter )
I put myself on assignment
down in Indonesia.
I went down there.
I wanted to expand.
I wanted to push
my boundaries again
as a photographer.
I wanted to be underwater.
I felt like, "Okay, I've
been up on the mountains.
How do I expand myself more?"
So I went down, and I wanted
to use imagery and media
to talk about things
in a cultural context.
The Bajau, they
were sea gypsies.
They always used
subsistence fishing.
They lived on the ocean,
and from the ocean.
And as the Indonesian government
has started to mandate
that they stay in one spot,
that has changed everything.
How do you tell that story?
That's a very important story.
Why?
Because as people stop moving,
they start to impact
the area they're in heavily.
Now that they're
in stilt villages,
they start to
overfish their reefs.
They start to overuse
their resources.
How do they do that?
They use net fishing.
But more importantly,
they use bomb fishing.
What happens to a reef
when you throw a bomb
in the water?
Sure, you get a lot of
fish out, and that's great.
But it's not great,
because it destroys
the whole marine ecosystem
in one fell swoop.
It's dead. It's gone. It's done.
I started to look at
storytelling and imagery
as a way to look at some
of the harder issues,
the issues that our
planet is facing.
How do we do that?
It's not just about science.
It's not just about adventure.
It's not just about culture.
It's about
how we as a human family
are impacting everything,
and only through pushing my own
boundaries as a storyteller
and having that
insatiable curiosity
could I continue to do that.
What does it look
like when we mandate
a way of life is
different from something
that everybody has always known?
It changes everything.
It changes everything instantly.
How do you put that in pictures?
How do you put it online
so that other people care,
so that they want to be
engaged with this culture?
My most recent assignment
for the magazine
was going to Franz Josef Land.
But that's again where I'm
trying to push boundaries.
I don't know how to tell
a natural history story.
I don't know but I'm going
to go and I'm going to try.
I'm going to try
to tell the story
of a changing
landscape, a landscape
that is changing because
of our human impacts.
Right?
What happens when we don't
take care of our planet,
when we are not stewards
of it in the right way?
Now, granted, this is a very,
very impactful photograph.
This is one tiny, tiny
piece of Franz Josef Land.
It's tiny.
But it's very, very
visual and graphic.
It tells you that
story instantly,
that we are a damaging species.
We are an invasive
species everywhere we go.
But I want to try and
expand myself always
and push boundaries of
adventure and storytelling
to give people a view that
they might not expect.
Is this the Arctic we think of?
No.
Big sandy plane?
Not at all.
How are we having that impact?
What is going on there?
What's our interface?
How do I get people excited
about bird populations,
the barometer of an ecosystem?
How do you do that?
How do you make
pictures that do that?
That's what-- I've changed
my whole way of thinking.
When once I was
completely devoted
to one thing, climbing,
to prove to everybody
that I was good enough,
I've now changed that and said,
"How do I prove to
everybody that we
are good enough
to change our problems?"
It's very, very simple.
Art is very simple.
The other day I was driving.
I'm in Yellowstone, and
I'm on assignment out there
trying to tell
a coexistence story.
Honestly, it's the hardest
thing I've ever done.
I moved up there.
I was a vegan
and I didn't drink.
I'm a carnivorous, functioning
alcoholic at this point.
( laughter )
I'm trying to figure out,
how do I bring all
of this together?
How do I tell this
story to this audience?
Because you guys are
all way smarter than me.
That's it.
Then I saw a bumper sticker.
That's where my
inspiration comes from.
Bumper stickers.
It was a very, very
simple bumper sticker.
It just said this.
It said a little
bit more than this,
but just this.
Art is not
a painting on the wall.
Art is not just
a piece of music.
It's all of that together.
Art is about
communicating ideas.
We have to readjust
how we think about art.
Art is everything.
Art is science.
Art is engaging our
kids in science.
There is an art to education.
Art is communicating ideas.
That's what the first
cave painting was about.
It was,
"I want to tell you this."
There is so much
information in this room,
and there is so much that we
have to share with each other,
in order to solve our problems
that we're facing as a planet.
When you think of this word,
you have to think of what
is at the heart of it,
right in the center of it.
That, in and of itself, alone,
with everybody in this room,
can change the
course of our future.
That's it.
That's my message.
It's very simple.
Taking the complex,
boiling it down,
to something that is beautiful,
simple, and complete
in itself.
So go forth and create.
( applause )
( outro music )